i feel like tom cried it like taxi
driver or something once like something
really like
he just wanted to drive
yeah
i think that mohawk looks really good
man the version of me that lives in your
head
i am talking to you i am talking to you
i'm trying to be your friend you're not
i just want to communicate i just we're
trying to have a dialogue you did a
really good job making a slidey gun
yeah
so today we're going to talk about the
most tear-jerking moments from animated
movies now obviously not all animated
movies will make you cry some that do or
the ones that you remember fondly are
the ones that you never want to watch
again but anyway we've got a list here
on looper.com full of movies that might
make you cry nina what are some
tear-jerking moments from animated
movies that reliably can make you cry
oh um well
i have two fun stories about some
entries on this list because i think the
biggest not offender but the biggest
tear factory in animated movies is pixar
like every pixar movie has a moment that
just makes you question you know your
place on earth and humanity and if
there's a god and stuff so i once cried
so loudly and intensely over the opening
of up on a mega bus that i was taking
from philadelphia to pittsburgh
that someone got up
and moved
to a different seat
i don't want to do this
this girl's nuts yeah um
like
like you can imagine what that person's
thinking the moment you start weeping
they're just like i gotta sit next to
the crying girl
all the way to pittsburgh no no brian
they weren't sitting next to me they
were sitting behind me and they still go
further away
yeah that's so much worse it's so much
worse so
and it's a seven hour mega bus ride from
philadelphia to pittsburgh it's a really
long ride and you watched up several
times
once i remember i had like downloaded a
bunch of movies to watch on the ride and
i just like i knew up with sad but i
didn't really think like i guess i
didn't believe people and i was like it
won't be that sad and then i'm like
blubbering like a like a newborn baby
while people are like oh
disturbed girl on the bus like
they've got like their phones out and
they have nine and one yeah
and they're gonna hit the last one when
you're freaking should we yeah should we
yeah
so that was up do we all call or does
one call do it yeah it's a bystander
effect thing like can we confirm
someone's doing it uh do we tell the
driver we still have we don't want to
overload the circuits in this
in this ride yeah so just been watching
ellie's death on repeat for the last
three 300 miles and uh that i did not do
it maybe she's
ramping up to something we gotta
i found what i think is a manifesto or a
shopping list i'm not sure she's playing
uptown girl at the same time and i just
think that's very special
so
that was a bad one the second one isn't
even as good that's the better story i
should have finished with that but uh
the second one is inside out which i had
seen five times already by the time i
turned it on on an airplane and i know
that there is like a there's like a
science reason why people cry more on
airplanes it's like has to do with like
air pressure or something there is there
have actually been studies about this
which i can tell you is true because a
good friend of mine once cried over
jumanji welcome to the jungle on an
airplane and that's his
excuse um oh no that's good to know
because yeah next yeah so i turned on
inside out i was like i've seen this
movie before i'm a nervous flyer so i
kind of like to watch stuff i've seen
because it's like comforting to me and
amy poehler started to speak and i burst
into tears and was like never mind next
movie i don't know why i've like i've
already seen it
anyway my pick is boo from monsters inc
the end of that movie makes me bawl it's
so sad boo is so cute the relationship
with sully is so good
monsters inc is probably i would say
probably my
my second favorite pixar movie and i
think inside out is first but monsters
inc has a very special place in my heart
it's funny
it's heartwarming and like when he has
to say goodbye to her and she doesn't
fully comprehend that that's what's
happening and it's like trying to play
with him like that is just so crushing
when she opens up the closet door
yeah no i'm like i'm like getting like
emotional thinking about it so i can't i
should stop talking about it but
i love
let's let's end the video quick yeah no
what crazy were you in when you saw that
movie what grade were you in well your
monsters didn't come out 12. um no what
year did monsters and come out
97
i think i was probably
monsters and came out in 2001 so it came
out when i was like 10 or 11 depending
on time of year so i probably saw it
shortly after i was probably like 11.
and i'm sure i just wept well brian
i thought you were teaching at a
university because you'd already
graduated yeah i was in college i had a
tenure yeah
because you're old yeah anyway because
i'm so old
um okay i'd like to jump off what's your
psychology class from dr henry jones jr
yeah that's right um
inside out yeah inside out though
that movie didn't didn't do much for me
and you haven't mentioned that yeah
the reason is because i spent so long
like getting wrapped up in my own head
trying to figure out like how
the inside of this kid's head worked
like the mythology of this universe yeah
i was like how did like do they like are
these little guys who aren't the
emotions like do they live like do they
have apartments like
do they go to sleep when she goes to
sleep but what about the people like i
like couldn't
i couldn't figure out like the
municipality situation
okay i don't disagree with you on this
this is actually i had the same thing i
was like okay wait does she have any
agency in her own life or are we all
just i couldn't stop thinking about the
structures of her mind
the people living in her brain function
and how they live i was like hang on a
second i ca i can't because if it's just
the emotions if it was for me if it was
just the emotions in the main part of
the brain that you saw the stars of the
show i'd be like all right fine got it
herman's head but for kids got it i'm
down no problem but then you start
inter-introducing like these pipes and
these like the movie studio for the
dream situation and bing bong shows up
and i'm like
i like to think that this is your
thought process on like any movie where
you like you know it's all well and good
but then there's pipes i don't know
anymore
into the pipe in the first place
hogwarts can't be real because magic
doesn't exist no
i'm just saying i couldn't that
particular movie took me out of it just
because i couldn't quite
wrap my head around really interesting
too because there was a huge like push
with that movie where like
neurologists worked with the writers to
figure out like a way to depict
how like the memory like the memory
system is like we have core memories and
then we kind of have like subsidiary
ones like that i mean do you ever think
about thinking do you ever think about
thinking and get freaked out about how
you're looking at something even though
you're looking at the way you will and i
have plenty of anxiety already so thanks
a lot brian you're very welcome anyway
my pick
is about most things
toy story three okay
um so how are the ones where the toys
accept their death
that was the one that was the moment so
here on the looper.com article we have
it's where andy gives the toys to that
is really sad that's really cool that's
a that's a very good moment for this but
for me it was when they're all in the
incinerator holding hands and my my wife
they've all come to terms with it yeah
yeah and i'm like
i just started i was crying like a
maniac
because i was just like what is
happening like these these toys are
about to die like i yeah one million
percent thought that the toys were about
to die so pixar does this a lot like
they play very fast and loose with like
like in wall-e when he like gets reset
you're like he's gone forever like it
yeah you're convinced right they they're
very good at being like no
we've taken this character away from you
and it's not as cruel no
it's never happened i don't know why i
keep falling for it it's because we're
all involved with trust issues yeah yeah
this is exactly why i don't and i i i
know i'm i'm not about to make any
friends every i i don't like pixar guys
oh no
and it's shut the video off of that
i don't like how much
they are that's exactly it like so i
think that inside out had the most
indicative
example of this and it's the scene where
they're like we're gonna make richard
kind into a cartoon elephant and then
have him say goodbye everybody like
there was no reason to do that besides
that they couldn't afford to send a guy
to every theater and stomp on the
audience's feet one at a time
and that's what picks our movies
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah anyone could be your sad
disappearing imaginary friend it's
richard kind like they didn't even have
to make him an elephant they could have
just animated
the first time that i noticed it was was
with up and it was the first time that
like i i got physically angry at uh
pixar movie it was still on a mega bus
i was on an amtrak
they disconnected my car and they
abandoned me in the middle of the
appalachian mountain i uh
no so like the year that up came out i
think i think it was 2008 is that right
nine i think 2009
it was the it was this it was this
really rough year for my family like my
my my
my dad was going through a bunch of
stuff and we're like you know what we
should do as kids we should we should we
should take my dad to see a fun movie
let's go see a fun cartoon together
and uh then the first five minutes of
that movie were hey don't forget that
everybody dies alone let's all just sit
in silence and contemplate the fact that
everybody dies alone
and they do that in every single one of
those movies and it drives me out the
wall like i i understand that we're
trying to make an uh an emotionally
connected story but my god man like
i'm sorry
dick move i'm just imagining i'm again
like it's happened to you and your
family and that that bums me out because
i know you guys yeah but in the abstract
the idea that like you as a family are
going through a rough time and you're
like i know what we need let's see a
[ __ ] movie right yeah
i have a similar story uh after my
grandpa died i took my cousin to the
movies to distract ourselves from it and
we saw the master of disguise
that didn't fix the
mean it took my story
off it took my mind off my dead grandpa
for 90 minutes and i was like what is
this
when my mother was having his hip
replaced my friend took me to see a star
is born which is not a happy ending
whoops and i remember being like well
i'm distracted at least by being very
sad about this movie instead die
[Music]
it's an ironic name considering how the
movie goes
anyway
um
other picks for this list so tom so you
you didn't have any picks for this list
iron giant though iron giant is high on
my list
i've never i've never cried you guys
when he's so i'm gonna i'm gonna spoil
iron giant and so i've already spoiled
it in one of our previous videos i'm
gonna spoil it now again so just click
away or mute me
okay so he's flying up in this through
space
towards the nuke and he goes superman
because he learned that superman's a
hero because he just closes his eyes and
then he blows up sacrificing himself to
save the earth it's so sad it's like
kills me every time okay spoilers are
over that that never made you cry
nah nah i didn't really feel anything no
when tom was born he didn't cry he just
made eye contact with his mother
i did
i stared her down
another really good one on this list tom
did you see coco
i never saw coco that is a good one
where he's so he's so he he connects
with uh his grandma and plays the song
the song that that her father had played
for her
and man that again my wife and i saw
that in the theaters and we just were
like weeping but that was like a weirdly
emotional day for us for some reason
because that was the movie that opened
with the olaf's insane christmas
short the 20 minutes short
that made us cry too and i don't know
why i thought you were saying that you
were just particularly vulnerable that
day because you got to watch so much
extra olaf
i don't know what it was but olaf going
around trying to find what makes
everybody happy on the holidays smashed
my soul it was just like guys you're
gonna cry now because holidays are magic
and i was just like yeah magic it's like
taking whatever they give you when you
get your wisdom teeth taken brian have
you ever cried over a nutcracker in the
four realms
i need to see that movie
maybe it'll make you cry
i hope so
i feel like
i feel like tom cried at like taxi
driver or something once like something
really like
he just wanted a dream
i think that mohawk looks really good
man the version of me that lives in your
heads is
i am talking to you i am talking to you
i'm trying to be your friend you're not
i just want to communicate it's just
we're trying to have a dialogue you did
a really good job making a sliding gun
yeah
the uh the only other one i want to add
that isn't on this list um but for me
so you mentioned that apparently you're
more susceptible to crying on planes
which is really good to know because i
saw moana on a plane
and that got me
immediately so did it where yeah oh my
god it's just and it's like it's and i
have like ptsd from it because we play
the soundtrack for our kids sometimes
and even that fun opening song when when
uh they sing that line and no one leaves
and i'm just like oh no one leaves
because they used to be way fairer than
so i cried at the end of that movie and
i was flying with my friend who's like
kind of like
like she's a if a shiba inu was a person
like she doesn't cry a lot
and
i was like oh no i don't want her to see
me cry like i've never cried in front of
her this is so weird but i looked over
and she was crying too and i was like
yes thank god okay we're both we're both
losers it's fine
yeah i told my wife on the flight like i
watched that on the flight and she like
fell asleep and i was just like you
should watch moana who made me cry a lot
and she watched it she was like that was
fine
no reaction to it he's just like yeah i
guess it was okay yeah the only other
instance i can think of where that kind
of thing happened on a plane was i suck
game night on a plane i didn't cry i
just laughed like such an
like an idiot
no i didn't cry during game night but i
was worried that people were going to
want to change shoes because i was
laughing like a maniac um try crying
next time they will move
i'll get my own seat
actually get a lot of people shot by an
air marshal
[Laughter]
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe and if you watch this far
please hit something and leave a comment
to tell us that you did because i don't
believe that anyone's looking at me
right now
you